we are here today because of the
invasion of ukraine uh the whole world
now knows that there was a full-scale
invasion ukrainian cities have been
bound
and we are here to show our solidarity
to ukrainian people with ukrainian
people
and support them in their fight for
their independence
sovereignty of
the country
and stand up to putin
i was born in ukraine
but today i think everybody is ukrainian
doesn't matter where you're born and
doesn't matter where you live people are
losing their lives right now
ukrainians are fighting
against
this regime
from russia and it's our
it's it's it's
it's really devastating
and he is causing suffering to people
around the world
we need we need help we need someone to
support us ukraine is too small
and the aggressor is too big they are
you know they're absolutely ignoring all
international laws they uh you know
they're killing civilians my friends
they're fighting in you know as
ukrainian troops and everything and
they're dying
for no reason it's our land we didn't do
anything wrong it just put in
submissions you gave support you pray
you can't support ukraine
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
is
[Music]
family
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a roller coaster of emotions
i feel
worried
sad and then if i receive the message
then there is
a slight hope
a moment and then it starts you start to
worry again